[Music]
i read a bunch of interviews that you've
done in the past you're always
referencing dangerous things you do
another thing and then i remembered that
uh
one of the last times that you were on
one of my shows you yes rode uh we rode
like
crazy uh jimmy johnson yes and so i
realized that neck and neck yes
you want did you win or i believe i
always win yeah of course he won yeah
yeah yeah but that's right but here's
the crazy thing is that i realized like
not a lot of guests do that you seem
like kind of a daredevil and then i hear
this rumor i don't know if it's true
that you jumped out of an airplane with
a parachute thank god yeah and that you
and this is down in florida and that you
drifted into cuban airspace right is
there any truth to this
none whatsoever
no i but uh there's got to be some truth
to it they don't just make up complete
lies they always take
some truth and then add something to it
yes well the truth uh part is that i did
walk by
a place where you could
skydive
i was on us-1 and i was driving by and
there was a place where you could go
skydiving and i went oh look skydiving
and then i kept going so that's really
the only
i never even went skydiving isn't that
crazy
i know no that's not true i did go
skydiving i went up in the plane
of course i did wait a minute
i don't now i honestly don't know
what happened yes and i think for good
reason why i don't understand
uh did you go skydiving
there was a time
when
what is this what is going on it will
i did go skydiving yes sir let's start
again you are christian slater are you
not
are you christian slater
let me think oh gosh okay
yes i did go skydiving but as far as
doing the cuban airspace thing i was in
key west i was 90 miles outside of um
cuba of course because the southernmost
point i think it's about 90 miles
it's 90 miles so
uh my parachute did start to drift
and uh head into some cuban airspace and
then as i was falling down um there was
a pool of sharks as well
uh that i was heading towards and uh
all of these boats started to circle us
and aim these phenomenal rifles up at my
and so one guy took a shot at my
parachute and blew a hole in the thing
and i started to plummet
very very quickly
to the earth headed right towards these
sharks whatever did you do
uh well fortunately uh cindy crawford
was there
uh
yeah so it worked out she had a little
boat and i landed right on that and
everything that's my story
[Applause]